SURVIVORS ARE.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE
TONIGHT.
KEVIN IS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WHERE THE PRESIDENT MADE A
SPEECH TO THE NATION THIS
MORNING.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH CORRESPONDENT
PHIL KEATING AT THE SHOOTING
SCENE IN PARKLAND, FLORIDA.
GOOD EVENING, PHIL.
>> Reporter: GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE ACCUSED HIGH SCHOOL KILLER
AT THIS HIGH SCHOOL BEHIND ME
DESCRIBED AS CALM AND COOL BY
THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF JUST
IN THE PAST 40 MINUTES, UPDATING
THE TIMELINE OF 19-YEAR-OLD
NIKOLAUS CRUZ'S TIMELINE OF
TERROR.
2:21 P.M. YESTERDAY, HE STARTS
SHOOTING INSIDE THOSE HALLWAYS
AND CLASSROOMS, HITTING FOUR
CLASSROOMS, AND WOUNDING OR
KILLING STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ON
TWO FLOORS.
HE THEN FLEES ON FOOT, BLENDING
IN WITH THE CROWD, GETS TO A
NEARBY WALMART.
BOUGHT A SODA.
THEN MEANDERS OVER TO A NEARBY
McDONALD'S AND ACTUALLY SITS
DOWN FOR A TIME BEFORE DECIDING
TO GO AHEAD AND KEEP ON WALKING.
AND IT WAS ONLY THEN, SHORTLY
THEREAFTER, HE WAS DETAINED AND
ARRESTED THANKS TO GREAT POLICE
WORK THAT CAUGHT UP WITH HIM.
>> ARE YOU NIKOLAUS JACOB CRUZ?
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> Reporter: 19-YEAR-OLD
NIKOLAUS CRUZ, 5'7" AND 131
POUNDS FACED A FLORIDA
MAGISTRATE THIS AFTERNOON, 24
HOURS AFTER ALLEGEDLY SHOOTING
AND KILLING 17 BOYS, GIRLS AND
FACULTY AT THE HIGH SCHOOL THAT
EXPELLED HIM LAST YEAR.
CRUZ IS CHARGED WITH 17 COUNTS
OF PREMEDITATED MURDER AND WILL
REMAIN HELD IN BROWARD COUNTY
CUSTODY.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO BE HELD, NO
BOND.
>> Reporter: UNLIKE OTHER MASS
SHOOTERS WHO TOOK THEIR OWN
LIVES, INVESTIGATORS SAY CRUZ
TRIED TO ESCAPE, PUTTING DOWN
HIS ASSAULT RIFLE AND BLENDING
IN WITH FLEEING STUDENTS FROM
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL.
INSIDE THE HIGH SCHOOL, HEAVILY
ARMED S.W.A.T. TEAMS, POLICE AND
DEPUTIES CLEARED OUT EACH
CLASSROOM, ONE BY ONE, RESCUING
TERRIFIED STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
WHO HAD BARRICADED THEMSELVES IN
HIDDEN CLOSETS.
>> TODAY'S NOT ANY EASIER THAN
YESTERDAY WAS.
ALL THE VICTIMS' FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN NOTIFIED.
>> Reporter: THURSDAY MORNING'S
UPDATE, THE FBI CONFIRMED IT HAD
BEEN ALERTED TO THE SUSPECT FOUR
MONTHS AGO FROM THIS YOUTUBE
POST, WHO CLAIMS SOMEONE WITH
THE SAME NAME AS THE SUSPECT
SAID, QUOTE, I'M GOING TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER.
>> I KNEW THAT I COULDN'T JUST
IGNORE THAT.
SO I SCREEN SHOTTED THE COMMENT,
SENT IT TO THE APPROPRIATE
AUTHORITIES.
>> THE FBI CONDUCTED DATABASE
REVIEWS, CHECKS, BUT WAS UNABLE
TO FURTHER IDENTIFY THE PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY MADE THE COMMENT.
>> Reporter: THE WORST HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTING IN U.S. HISTORY,
EXCEEDING COLUMBINE BY TWO
FATALITIES
FATALITIE
FATALITIES.
ACCORDING TO THE SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT, THE SUSPECT
ARRIVED IN AN UBER.
ACCORDING TO INVESTIGATORS, HE
THEN SHOT AND KILLED THREE
PEOPLE OUTSIDE, THEN WENT
INSIDE, PULLED A FIRE ALARM AND
WHILE WEARING A GAS MASK AND
CARRYING MULTIPLE MAGAZINES, AS
WELL AS SMOKE GRENADES, STARTED
SHOOTING AT STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS AS THEY FLOODED INTO
THE HALLWAY.
HE THEN FLED.
A POLICE OFFICER SPOTTED THE
SUSPECT IN A NEIGHBORHOOD ABOUT
A MILE AWAY, AND ARRESTED HIM.
>> I PULLED MY VEHICLE OVER
IMMEDIATELY, ENGAGED THE
SUSPECT.
HE COMPLIED WITH MY COMMANDS.
>> WE OFFER THESE WORDS, OH
GOD --
>> Reporter: STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES GATHERING OUTSIDE THE
SCHOOL GROUNDS, TRIBUTES AND
MEMENTOS FOR THE VICTIMS.
ON THE FENCE OUTSIDE THE POLICE
LINE, NOW HANGS 17 CROSSES.
ONE CROSS PER VICTIM, PLACED
THERE BY CHAPLAIN ROBERT OSD
THERE BY CHAPLAIN ROBERT OS
THERE BY CHAPLAIN ROBERT OSTL
THERE BY CHAPLAIN ROBERT OSTLER
THERE BY CHAPLAIN ROBERT OSTLER.
>> THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
PIMPLING, THEY SHOULDN'T WORRY
ABOUT A WAR ZONE.
>> Reporter: A VIGIL HAS NOW
BEGUN AT THE CITY OF PARKLAND
AMPHITHEATER, AN OPEN-AIR PARK.
WE'RE EXPECTING MANY HUNDREDS IF
NOT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO
ATTEND TO PAY HOMAGE AND
COMMEMORATE THE LIVES OF THOSE
17 PEOPLE KILLED AT THIS HIGH
SCHOOL YESTERDAY.
AND OF COURSE, EXPRESS
CONDOLENCES AND GRIEF TO THEIR
FAMILIES WHO HAVE HAD THEIR
FAMILIES ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED AND
DESTROYED.
IT REMAINS A VERY COMPLEX AND
ACTIVE, HUMONGOUS CRIME SCENE
INVESTIGATION, MORE THAN 2,000
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWED SO
FAR.
MORE WILL FOLLOW.
ALSO, THE INVESTIGATORS ARE
STILL ANALYZING THE SCHOOL'S
SURVEILLANCE CAMERA VIDEOTAPE,
TRYING TO EVEN BETTER PIECE
TOGETHER THE ALLEGED GUNMAN'S
TIMELINE, FOR EXAMPLE, WHY WERE
ONLY THOSE FOUR CLASSROOMS